et pour tirer au doigt un délégué
syndical grant west pour alternatif
police de la cfdt ces incidents sont une
nouvelle démonstration de la mauvaise
foi de groupuscules violents qui
s'introduisent dans toutes les
manifestations
c'est forcément d un raisonnement qui
est contre l'état contre la police donc
forcément c'est quelque chose qui ne
compte pas entendre et c'est quelque
chose et aussi c'est un comportement on
va dire révolutionnaire qui va pour s'en
prendre à la collectivité et ça on ne
peut pas le tolérer et il faut savoir
quand même que quand on a le droit de la
police a le droit d'utiliser la force
légale pour pouvoir dispersés sur
sommation donc quand on prévient la
foule dispersée doivent le faire sinon
la force légitime pour pouvoir le faire
donc ça vous dit c'est aussi ça plus
d'éventuelles violences qui pourraient
être commises à la marge et en ce qui
concerne d'éventuelles violences c'est
la part il faut les étudier au cas par
cas voir si ce prix mais quoi qu'il
arrive ce qu'il faut c'est que d'une
manière générale les politiques
condamnent et c'est ce qui s'est passé
d'ailleurs
condamne fermement voilà ce genre de
comportement qui n'eut à tout le monde
d'ailleurs il faut bien comprendre que
la population est excédée de ce genre de
comportement et les commerçants les
commerçants qui subissent déjà une
surprise je pense qu'ils ont un espace
très largement de ce genre de
comportement